thank you all so much for for joining
today welcome back to the data science
hangout
and for anybody who's
new to the data science hangout
this is really just a open space
for current and aspiring data science
leaders to connect and
chat about some of the more
human-centric questions around data
science leadership
but really to focus on questions that
are most important to you all
so if you haven't been here before
there's
three ways to ask questions so you could
jump in live
put questions in the chat
or we do also have a slido link
i do have to go and get that and share
that with rob and he'll put in the chat
window
um
and rob actually a quick note if you
could message monty for the slide of a
link i realized he didn't send it to me
um
but also this will be recorded and
shared up to youtube for anybody who's
missed it
but i'm so excited to be joined by my
co-host for today
kobe who's the senior vice president of
data science and analytics at warner
music group
and kobe be great to maybe just have you
start by introducing yourself and
sharing a bit about your team and the
work that you do
my name is kobe uh right now i'm the
senior vice president for
what's called research and analytics at
uh warner music
uh it's a music company so this is one
of the
places in the world where
people off the street are turned into
artists and
people who like music are turned into
fans
um
these days the
delivery
of music
is quite different from what has been
historically uh
and the vast majority of money that
comes into any music company label like
this uh is through electronic listening
right so the way in which we consume
media
at large it's mediated by the delivery
um
so media companies this one in
particular
now with this one something digital it's
automatically leaving a trail or record
or an experiment or observations and so
it's a natural place for for data
science work which is concerned with
being able to tell what's going on uh
from from reams of data from
observations so the experiment
you know that we're trying to model
here is who listens to what right and so
what
is a big deal how to categorize and
quantify music
uh in an information
way and then who
uh the the problem that media companies
uh have been wrestling with
uh as people's behaviors change from you
know retail and going into a store and
buying something to to digital being
able to understand audiences what they
like
how to curate them how to market to them
how to address them
uh in a way that that so that they make
sure they're choosing your content and
then they're choosing
uh
your content to put their eyeballs and
ears on uh in the overall sort of span
of competitive
uh
media or attention sources
so so that's where we exist part of it
is understanding music and part of it's
understanding people and for anybody
who's in a media company
um a lot of the things that
i imagine we'll talk about this hour
will be familiar uh our work on audience
um is familiar to people who like work
at a comcast or warner media where i
used to work before this
uh or any of the ad tech space a lot of
stuff is gonna sound familiar
kobe while we're waiting for some
questions to come in i think it'd be
really cool to hear about like an
example of
a problem that your team's working on
right now
um
right so so let's talk about a problem
with from the perspective of audience
one of the things that music companies
are good at have been good at is sort of
curating a fan base right like artist x
these are the people who listen to
artifacts and sort of keeping
uh attention and pushing some turning
turning a young person into a dualipa
say
um
and
my team right now is focused on being
able to extract from the information we
do get from the people who deliver our
music
um
a a a refined and high resolution sense
of of that fan base in that audience uh
we receive from the people who
distribute our music these are the
spotifys the apple music the amazon
information
on and i would say even down in the
transaction level
so very high frequency really highly
resolved information on how people are
interacting with our
our inventory our property
but
uh mast and blinded and a lot of the
information sort of left out right um
and this anybody who works in media will
be familiar with this conundrum when i
was at warner media uh
people would watch our shows but they
would watch it on comcast comcast has a
box on your on your you know on your
mantel you have the relationship with
comcast comcast knows what you like in a
really high sort of frequency sort of
way
we get the information back from comcast
a lot of that high frequency information
is left out right you get certain sort
of aggregate way that's the same thing
here even when we have information down
the transactional level like hey
somebody listen to 9 45
in the morning and the houston dma to do
alipa's track we don't know who it was
we don't know anything else about them
uh we just
are able to observe the consumption so
we're really strong on observing
consumption and so a big part of what we
try to do is join consumption patterns
to what we can infer about people and
their behavior um a lot of this is is is
known in um
in ordinary visual media as fusion right
probabilistic joining how do you take uh
a data set
resolve an individual level and join it
to other data sets we have information
about people and populations
strata information and so we spend a lot
of time
figuring out how to join what we can see
and what people listen to to
saying things about who they are and and
so there's a lot of work that goes into
that
and
kobe what does what does your team look
like how many data scientists do you
have or
are you really still building that team
as well yeah yeah so i'll say this
i
walked into a team that um
so
the name of the you know the group is
research and and and analysis
and um
i walked into a team last year that i
would say more analysis and research and
and
you know not hesitant saying this sort
of thing what is data science right like
we have only been calling
what we do
uh data science you know 10 12 13 years
at the most a guy who i used to work for
back in his professor jeff wu uh
is is credited with coming up with the
name data science and you know
incorporating the computational
aspect of statistics into the name and
that you know that name's really taken
off
a lot of organizations
um
as they're you know beset with uh to put
it so straight the wolves at the door
the people who
who have these wild environments and
have really good
consumer information these are the
facebooks in the news these days these
are the amazons these are netflix uh
realized that they needed to create
their own data science organizations and
you know name them as they will from
coming from whatever space they they
they came from
warner music's no different realized you
know mute
and then beset with the new delivery
mechanism for music and and
created a group to match that and
[Music]
a period paragraph most of what went on
uh prior to 20 20 i say was was more
sort of analysis and that's people
taking consumption side data univariate
data really right how many people listen
to this track
um how many people see this track this
week versus last week and packaging that
up into reports and so what we've been
doing this year is is is going from
analysis to actual
research and and the way that i like to
say this to the team um is
it's cause and effect um this is where
statistics can be useful if you do this
this happens conditional expectation
this is the fundamental utility of tools
like regression being able to explain
demand side numbers in terms of the
levers and buttons that a business can
press and more than that the exogenous
factors that affect things right uh and
so we spent a lot of time this year
standing up
uh not just a model to be able to
to place demand in context of business
action and ambient effects
but the internal pipeline is necessary
to be able to do so right like when you
want to do something at scale
it's one thing to do it once and one at
a regression on thing it's another thing
to to do it every several hours or do it
instantaneously and have the data
pipeline so that things are moving
correctly and so we spent a lot of time
this year standing up a proper
data science pipeline
kind of
going along with that question oh and
also just to let everyone know rob just
shared in the chat the slido link if you
want to ask any anonymous questions as
well
um
but kobe last week we were chatting a
bit about
like
data engineering and then
data scientists
and wondering like
at what point do you
hire data engineers or data scientists
like do you have to have data engineers
first
to be able to make sure everyone has
access to data
yeah that you know that's not that's a
great question
yeah yeah the answer is yes
you know
excuse me
we were lucky to walk into at this place
a pretty strong um
data engineering team
that had been
dealing with the volume of data that
they get from the uh the distributors
again this is a spotify napa music
world so we did we didn't you know
we didn't have to construct that
and that wasn't
within um that wasn't one of the bricks
that we needed to lay
having said that though
uh data engineering is more than just uh
data munching and and pipelining and
stuff like that it's it's illustrations
it's display it's it's using technology
to be able to push things back out
and so we have
hired a couple people and rely on people
who are strictly data engineers you know
some organizations have these have these
tasks separate
we're lucky to have here uh people with
those skills in the same group so that
the conversation's always happening and
going and it and it guides a lot of the
modeling right like
um these days with the sort of model
that we're using and we're a bayesian
shop
which
relies on a fair amount of um
probabilistic computing
the data engineers knowing that from the
beginning right can construct uh systems
and compute methodologies that match the
methodology that we're using sort of the
theoretical methodology i've been places
where those are totally separate but
it's good to have them within the same
team here
i get to ask you all these questions
while we're waiting for some to come in
oh i see frank you just asked a question
would you want to ask it live yeah for
sure uh that totally caught my ear um
when you said we are a bayesian shop uh
i think i mentioned on on this meetup a
few weeks ago maybe months ago that i'm
always trying to become more busy and
so i'm kind of curious like did you did
your group just start out that way did
you hire a bunch of people who were
really into
um that way of thinking
is there any backstory
yeah there is you know back when i was a
little boy
uh one of my first advisor in grad
school was andrew gellman and when i did
a postdoc i did it at duke which is a
big bayesian place
and
as data science has has matured and
honestly the computation on that site is
also matured i've always wanted to
impose that in in production
um if you want to and these things
aren't really separable because a lot of
you know the fundamental stuff
underneath both
is the same
but um
you'll see a lot of places throw i guess
what they call sort of
machine learning
uh models at things which i consider
just sort of you know high volume data
frequency type of models make that an
estimator once and then
recompute when you need to do it
one of the things that i wanted to do
here was
have a system where we didn't always
have to
to recompute things and where we could
rely upon
sorry rely upon over time
really having well specified uh
posterior distribution that we could
just draw from
for inference for explanations of the
business before this i worked at a
um
warner media and we were doing random
effects there right which is really just
a sort of you know baby version this is
the smallest stacking doll inside the
beijing world and i was like well if we
can do that in production we can really
do the full thing and what that's used
for it for us let me give you an example
we uh
in the model we use for forecasting we
have parameters that govern
the speed of growth
in listening demand to something to a
song right this business is often
questioning
uh is this becoming a hit is this
becoming a hit is this becoming a hit
right and so now we have a way of having
uh
distributions to draw from for these
parameters you know for this parameter
particular right this house is this
thing becoming a hit and we can compare
a song's performance
online immediately right in terms of
what the posterior looks like uh to our
baseline for is this becoming a hit or
not and that's mediated by the full
model that we use which is
a hit in countries a different thing
from a hit in in pop a hit in nigeria's
different thing from a hit in uk
and
so now the questions that the business
ask are automatically baked in to the
procedure that we're doing right there's
nothing extra to do
uh you really it's just model
interpretation now right and and so
that's one of the things i preach is you
want to get people out of
rescraping data and recomputing frequent
things every thought every time to
answer the experiment again after the
experiment again the experiment is a
long
process and each one of these iterations
a track and is it a hit is it merely an
instance
right of
of one it's a sample from the overall
experiment what is a hit
and we want to use prior knowledge as
much as we can and we bake our so the
system is set up to bake in prior
knowledge
one uh anonymous question is
from following up on that what's an
example of a hit song you discovered
through this model
uh you know i i don't know people tell
one of our wonder music artists is uh
aya nakamura and there was a song that
was
one of the tricks in the music business
is you have a song that's doing well you
want to get it to do better in a local
market you park you remix or partner
with an artist who's popular locally
right and so she was sort of this the
song was shopped around
different markets and a couple places we
could see it hitting i can't remember
the name of the song
it's in a different language she uh she
sings sometimes in french and sometimes
in spanish yeah
aya nakamura look yeah look her up she's
great she's fantastic you'll like it
that's awesome david i see you just
asked the question in the chat as well
do you want to can i pass the mic to you
um sure yeah i mean it's just a general
question um you know just in addition to
the high level data that you get from
your distributors like apple music
spotify etc do you guys ever integrate
data from other sources like social
media to learn more about your audience
yeah the answer is yes
for for pop music at least
uh i think a big part of what the
the business understands
uh as audience behavior is social media
behavior right
um again
that's that's the effect of that is
different across genres
you know i could just say for instance
we've noticed that
the classical audiences have a
almost uh
you know pervert no relationship but
perverse relationship to social media
right like if something's doing well a
social media classic it's not being
listened to
um
so so
it has different importance depending
upon what the sort of music is but yeah
we that's a big part of one of our
inputs yeah
for that example of the the model like
is this song
going to be a hit
how does your team
share that model or publish it or what
kind of tools do you use
yeah you know so we we write a lot of
stuff in uh we've
we've
beaten up streamlit this year we've used
that over and over and over again
uh for illustrations
um i'll say this so this is and this is
more sort of the you know the sort of
corporate sort of thing and like what
structure should be
it's my opinion that that you know
visualizations and something that this
is really sort of outside of the uh
productionized visualization let's say
that it's it's you're pushing the the
remit
of a data science team right like some
people who are really good at that like
that's what they really do like i'm a
javascript front-end guy right
um and limited resources you hire
javascript front end guy don't expect to
get anything else out of him so uh in a
mature organization
right you want to be able to sort of
illustrate and poc and things like
streamlit but then like in for mature
production like you want to get people
especially in a business like the music
business where
you know the people are generally
artistic sort of people and so having an
app that's really sort of beautiful uh
you want to be able to rely on the
organization
for that last
sort of
bit of productionization which is make
this thing beautiful
and and have a really beautiful app
around it but for us for ourselves to
get to that point we we use streamline
how do you partner with
that creative team or what does that
process look like
you know that this is always the
question in in so-called data science
and and
um
i'm
from a broad scope i think you could
reframe this question like how do you
explain quantitative concepts to
to people audiences colleagues students
who are qualitative right uh
you know working with the
the zeitgeist we live in and and and
businesses is just so super important
um
to be able to do meaningful work to to
tie in with people who
who don't do that work and who it's
you know novel to
uh
at this business so music business this
is
i should say a little bit more about the
music business federated business right
so there's a central sort of corporate
function and then there's the labels
everybody's heard this the label you've
listened to the rap songs i want to get
my own label one of the label signs
i got screwed by the label these are the
people who
interact with the artists directly and
there's many of them in any you know
large muted company that
manifold labels different people
their their tasks idiosyncrasies are
sort of bespoke
and unique
and so a lot of that i can't really give
you like a bible for um it's sort of
going around
the building
and and working with people you know
i'll say this this might be useful i say
this to my team
you know any company there's four people
who are doing real work
find those four people
especially in data science you need to
find the people whose jobs count
on the actual measurable outcomes and if
you get those people
onto your stuff and you know drinking
from your bottle
uh
what you create will be successful
so what are those measurable outcomes
well in this business the metro outcomes
is
whether songs are successful or not
media in general this one in particular
one of the things
that people in media are very worried
about is your overall sort of attention
budget
um so it's like sort of a stick breaking
problem you can imagine the dirichlet
distribution on your day
uh each of the dimensions being what you
paid attention to and so in music you
want if if this is the
amount of the of the of the time you're
gonna listen to music
we want it warner music
to be listening to our inventory so
that's market share so market share is a
big driver
in this business the way that the music
companies are paid
are basically off of fraction of
subscription fees right
you pay spotify spotify takes your 100
whatever
and splits it up
uh amongst by shares
uh
amongst the the rights holders for those
shares right
uh so if there's only a hundred dollars
to go around i want
as much of 100 as possible i need people
to listen to
my stuff more than they listen to
the other person's stuff right
and you see this especially in pop right
very sort of competitive
uh setup a song comes out
people worry about release schedules
because they don't want
the amount of available listening
to to be shared or diluted or diffused
you know among many different options
do you have a model that helps predict
the release schedule for your artist
you know so that's one of the things we
work on
um
when i walked into this job you know as
i was interviewing for it and noticing
what they did one of the things i
noticed immediately is that
if
we have an understanding of audiences
and
and where they are and how they listen
to things in the world
right now i've characterized an audience
in a sort of disparate
geolocated and even temporal way right
this is an optimization problem
you know so and what's what's to be
optimized
how i offer my inventory at different
times now a lot of this is mediated by
the uh the way in which people listen to
things now right
which is
i can go on apple music and everything's
available at every time i you know i can
listen to i can
you know sophisticated user
uh but much of it still is very temporal
right the way in which things are pushed
the way in which things are playlisted
uh release schedules are very
important
um i can't say much more about that you
know tonight we're at the edge of of
stuff that's sort of
that i want to be famous for
but uh but yes yeah we're concerned
about that
thank you
there's a few anonymous questions that
are coming in too and
um one was
based on what you said previously around
like those four people how do you work
with or really around the people who are
outside the four that are really doing
work
yeah you know so those people who the
and i'm just being straight for anybody
who works a job you you'll this will
resonate
um
there are males people there at the
company too right like the there's a
there's 4 000 people around those four
people
um
and you you spend time satisfying them
and placating them
super important in data science again
because it's opaque because people i
think have a natural sort of
disinclination to
to numeracy
um
you know championing what you do
i what i tell
my team
and this this is this i think it's a
nuanced thing to say and i do want to
say this so when i tell my team make it
about the work
and what you produce
think of what you're doing it's adding
to your dossier and i think that that
resonates it resonates for me i think it
resonates for people who've dedicated a
long swath of their life to
acquiring the technical acumen to even
do these sorts of jobs right i say
you're building
your dossier for this job for your next
job here for your next job somewhere
else right and you and you want to make
you want to make your story uh as part
of your creation part of working these
jobs is is dealing with the friction and
other things that go on and for a leader
you know that's my job
to gladhand smile keep people off your
that's your butt and
and give and give people the space to
create
uh i will say this and this i think this
is relevant to say too
one of the things i think
much of the business world
uh
is having to contend with you know with
effective data science is the way in
which data science teams are integrated
into the ordinary sort of business
function and that sounds sort of top
level and opaque but that's as real as
how people who are scientific and
non-scientific relate
talk to each other
enjoy each other go out to dinner have
conversations sit in meetings schedule
meetings with one another right like
that's how it works
what i say to the people at this company
and the people on my team
google might not have had this problem
in the beginning it started off with two
computer scientists right i'm sure they
didn't have to convince
you know somebody
who didn't have the same background on
the utility of a page rank algorithm
um
most other data science organizations
aren't free of that worry and so it's a
big part of what we do
uh in being conversant
uh yeah with the organization
definitely
daniel i see you asked a really good
question in the chat and would love to
have you ask that live
sure uh absolutely um so this just kind
of goes back to the the similar stream
of thoughts that you've been speaking
about
uh in terms of kind of like those four
people to use that that same example but
um
you kind of
uh
put it in the context of like the people
that can really kind of uh knock out
those things that are really worth
knocking out they can kind of uh ace the
tesla to speaker or get them
uh produce the metrics that need to be
produced
would you have kind of like any
strategies or any advice when kind of
like the
the generally accepted metrics that are
used by other parts of the business
aren't really what you think they should
be
so like if you're you're personally
measuring your team based on something
and the business is saying like you
should actually be measuring something
else or this other thing is important to
us how do you kind of bridge that gap
yeah that's a great question i'll blab
for a second i'll tell you that
i hope my answer is satisfying the
reason i say that is because this is a
real
problem right
you're in organizations that have been
doing things one way i even expanded to
that and and what you've been hired
though to do is to bring them the gospel
of what's new but the way that they
read the gospels and the language they
already understand
uh and so this
this is um
it's always an issue it's always
something to think about it's all it's
top of mind every day i get up
and and
contend may not be
connote the sort of positivity in which
you can deal with it
um but but it's it's
yes so the answer is yes
so i'll give you a specific example
so the growth thing that i told you
about in the model
uh that i described where we have a
parameter that measures sort of rate of
growth so the the parameter that we use
and the model that we use
the the the thing we're parameterizing
is not just rate of growth but it's rate
of growth
per sort of expected total addressable
audience right
uh
one of the things i noticed when i got
here so we would pass around reports of
the previous iteration of the
organization
on sort of what's growing and what's the
top hit
not baseline right like you would see
graphs and people would play around with
the y-axis and you would see you know
here's this thing is really growing
right and then and it's
you know logarithmically different from
a growth rate for something else
um
i i and i'll tell you for the way that
we parameterize it we try to get the
conversion into money as as quickly as
possible
um
demand will be different things in
different business right like the top
line volume of demand you're always
hitting that with a
with a rate card and i'm using some
media jargon sort of stuff
uh so
one of my worries was
getting from demand to
to revenue
and then from revenue to market share
real quick because i knew that those
were metrics that the business could
understand and and that they evaluated
themselves on
uh so it's one thing to say growth is
one of the things they both addressed
you know of total addressable market
it's another thing to say
if this thing grows like this this is
how much more money and market share
you'll get
uh i found that to be effective when you
say that people
uh
seem to pay attention
you as long as you're you're you're back
in uh dollars or yen or pounds
uh one other anonymous question kobe is
are songs themselves analyzed to
understand what makes the song popular
in certain regions
um like nlp for a lyric sentiment
no fantastic question
the answer is yes
the answer and also there's a lot more
to do there
um
this company other companies
you know separate companies that suggest
to do this uh do spend time thinking
about the sound
content itself
the lyrics themselves
again you know so the fundamental object
in the music business is
is is who is listening to what right
what how it sounds so that would be our
way to quantify and categorize the sound
the lyrics stuff like that but the the
response side of it is who and so what
we are spending time here is well now
that i'm able to quantify this thing uh
in a measurable way
how do
audience segments respond to these
quanta right like
um
turns out
uh people who listen to kids music
uh might not be big fans of profanity
you know things like that right like so
that this it gets meaning when you cross
over from the content itself to the
audience that receives it and what
you're trying to get as far as change
and demand yeah
i wonder if
like would songs themselves start to
sound
more similar if people were trying to
like follow this like you know that's a
that's a great question but i'll tell
you so this is not my area we've
actually been lucky to hire a guy who
specializes in music information but
i'll tell you from what i understand
from it is actually the answer is the
opposite is that people
tend
to enjoy
things that sound novel or orthogonal
right those are the things that turn
into hips so it's not
we're not actually if you're trying to
get people to listen to stuff this is so
what's so beautiful
about music it's almost you know like
you're you're dealing with sort of the
fundamental sort of questions of
existence
no just playing a tone at 440 hertz
isn't going to make a hit right and so
if people are worried about the
algorithms would just be like
stuff like that that's not that's not
what people respond to i know we have
the weirdos who like to hear packages
being unwrapped but in general for most
people people like to hear novel things
and that's what sort of catches their
ear
cool thank you
bruno i see you asked a question in the
chat if you want to jump in live
hi thanks for doing this
uh i wanted to know do you
do you do the same kind of work for the
back catalog like the the older music
is it generating enough revenue to
warrant the same analysis level
i i'm so glad you asked this question so
i'm gonna say several things
first the answer is yes second this is
the perfect question to ask
an old foggy like me because i i you
know so enemy a little preface and this
is just in the
you know the course of conversation when
i was interviewing for this job and you
know and decided to take this job one of
the things i told them was uh when i
used to um
when i was in grad school my part-time
job i was a dj
and um but i was one of those sort of
obtuse
you never heard this song before and
made me proud if you've never heard the
song before
dj's right like i i used to say that i
could
i could play a whole set with never
playing a record more than uh
30
more recent than 30 years
old and and there's there's a wealth
there is a wealth of stuff in catalog
right like
it's my belief you could run a whole
radio station off of
the the diaspora of music from
1980 backwards never play a new song and
get stuff that sounds topical and fresh
and beautiful and competes orally with
any of the stuff that's come out now so
the answer is yes we um
very concerned
uh about about catalog and back
catalogue at warner music the label for
catalog is called rhino they have a lot
of inventory of really really good stuff
aretha franklin
last year we they had a big uh run with
um fleetwood mac that's in the catalog
yeah so the answer is yes now the second
part of that is
again
how do people listen to things these
days right how is music distributed
whereas before
you know you had to get some kid
interested in led zeppelin so that they
would go down to the store and cough up
their 14 to get that led zeppelin cd and
you'd hope that this
would happen in an evergreen way
nowadays a kid can just go onto
the dsp and type in led zepplin and
you know
hear stuff from the 70s
so there's a tremendous opportunity to
curate and push that stuff and then the
last thing i'll say there is
that the um
the streaming providers are aware of
this uh they're already doing it right
uh they they have this stuff in-house as
part of the inventory that they're
paying for
uh they push it you know serious pandora
pushes it in a channel sort of way they
do an amazing job at curating
listing within these sort of older
catalog based
uh
tranches
uh and they also do a great job of sort
of pushing the boundary like hey if you
listen to this new thing here's this old
thing and then pushing it out uh
i i'm not an expert in this
but
the the rights are different between
like new recorded music and some of the
older
stuff uh some of the old catalog stuff
but for sure so the answer the last part
what you have is older music generating
enough revenue streamed or warrant
analyzing yeah yes yes capital y es
thank you it's interesting we've already
had two djs on as featured speakers then
and sep i will call on you next for your
question then
oh man
yeah
um yeah so i was just curious um
i'm i'm by no means
a professional in this uh in this space
but i was just curious if like you know
there are data sources that um
that maybe
are outside of what you would
traditionally get and i was just
thinking you know a lot of djs are using
digital software these days whether
they're through beatport subscriptions
or or whatnot and um sometimes they
stream or whatever uh i wonder if that
might be an interesting data source i'm
not sure for what but
just trying to think outside the box a
little bit yeah i know the there's also
these sort of sample packaging services
where they've sort of pre-cleared stuff
and they offer sort of a suite
of things all of those are interesting
data sources uh and i know warner music
has a relationship with some of these
people right uh for the reselling of
rights
um i think that those are interesting
signals uh you you find
uh in some of the the dj stuff what i
think you know presages what becomes
popular right like i remember there was
a track
uh what was this
had a meter sample in it this is mid 80s
or something like that
mid mid aughts it was around 2006 2007
what was the young lady's name she had
two singles
one single one album a couple years
passed and she had another big single
uh and the song really again orthogonal
very different from people listening to
at the time
but you know having dj'd in brooklyn in
the early 2000s
people were playing a lot of these you
know sort of acid jazz esque funk meters
type type beats and so when that came
out
in in pop and and and it's coming out in
pop because the people who are producing
the music are hearing this stuff seeing
the response to it and then packaging it
up you know around a pop artist and
track
the name of the song was like one thing
and i wish i could remember the artist's
name but
um
that sort of stuff yeah
a strong signals for what might be
fertile in the future
there's a anonymous question um what
predictors do you consider for
when you're actually making these
predictions
well we talked a little bit about aural
characteristics right this the sound
quality itself quantity itself sorry um
the
things that are sort of categorical
which type of artist
which genre although
we're trying to have a
more continuous notion of genre rather
than just a sort of category
her name was amaree a-m-e-r-i-e yup
that's exactly right thanks
there's a seasonality
into the way people listen to things
right so so there's seasonality built
into our models
um
a
big part of what we do is is is not
having to
lean on the models for a huge amount of
covariance but being intelligent and
this is really the same thing if you
think about it uh being intelligent on
how we select things that are comparable
for prediction right like
for instance
if and this is not exactly what we do so
say somebody came up with a song that we
found was very similar to the to the
amory song right we would use that and
how people listen to that
uh as a predictor for what you might see
for this new song
well thank you
i'm noticing a there was a question
earlier that i had missed when you were
talking about
using streamlit
someone asked are there similar to your
discussion of streamla any thoughts on
shiny and its place in production
organization oh yeah yeah i i love shiny
um
and
so for the stuff that i do sort of more
bespoke somebody wants a dashboard on
something sort of unique i strictly use
shiny and you know what i'll say this i
i i
very hands-on
person you know i lead the team but i i
code i create absent shiny i was fussing
around with it yesterday rachel knows
that i think her all the time about can
i get some help to make sure this thing
works
so we use that all the time um
it's a big part of what we do
thank you are there any other questions
that
anyone had that i maybe missed already i
was just scrolling through oh another
anonymous question is
do you have colleagues insisting on
giving you data in google sheets
how do you work with them if all your
data is warehoused they said then i am
so jealous
yeah yeah i look when we when i came and
when i started this job the answer was
yes so we had to and that that's just
not a
efficient way
to do anything useful right that's um
you're trying to cook for an army and
here's your pot and your can of beans
that just doesn't work
so i feel for you
so is that to say most of your data is
warehouse now
what is that the last majority of our
data is warehouse and we spend time
worrying about making sure stuff is and
pipeline before we before we use it
right um i i can't even think of a time
recently where somebody just threw
something at us and
and we were forced to just download it
from the google sheet or or save as dot
csv uh yeah you know
if you want to try to push organizations
to get away from things like that
you know i found some data on the street
see what you can do with it
um
one of our
i think it was actually two weeks ago we
did have a pretty big discussion on
becoming a manager and taking that jump
from being able to do
spend most of your time doing coding and
then moving into this manager role but
it sounds like you
are still also doing that coding part
so i'd love to hear a little bit more
about that
yeah i mean
i think that's important i i don't
you know i'm not even this is sort of
you know phil's philosophy well the
first thing i'll say is you know having
a team and having lots of people
beautiful people who are willing to to
to tie in to to make what you're trying
to do successful not just me
but the company and all that and that's
a privilege and i say that and i
remember mine if if if the people you're
hiring and you don't feel like that
about them you're hiring their own
people right like
that it's a gift
that they're giving you you know their
talent and their time and
you can never pay them for when they
were eight years old they were taking a
toy apart right or they were you know
studying biology on the train when they
were 13. you can't pay people for those
things
um
and as far as as as the work
you know the point of having a team is
because there's only one you know
there's only one of you
there's only so much you can do for
yours by yourself for yourself and part
of you know being a manager is
is is is curating the team
and then providing a vision and
and and being a decent person
but part of being a manager is also
doing in my opinion right and i and i
think the best organizations demonstrate
that that's my opinion that's my
philosophy
i i'd have to
that prior is really strong and narrow
no i'd have to see stuff in the other
direction
where i felt good about being a leader
who didn't do any work the same with
other people yeah
how do you balance that
and figure out like
that
like what time you can use on on
actually coding yourself and
you know so for me in particular i'm a
morning person i get up really early i'm
up at like 4 30 4 45 in the morning
before nine o'clock in the morning
before everybody else is up that's when
i'm doing you know the individual work
that that's that's on my plate
uh and then during the day i'm having
conversations sometimes at night i'll
pick up a little bit more because that
works for me right to have a the day
ordered that way
also i um
really echo frank's
comment in the chat too that it's
it's amazing that perspective on being
grateful to people that come in and work
with you
we just
asked we just asked this question to
a few people from the team here in
iceland and i'd love to ask you it as
well
um
was there a certain
point in time where
like in your life you said wow you
really can
achieve amazing things with data like
what got you into data in the first
place in the first place you know so
i'll go away you know my father was a
was a psychologist and he finished grad
school
when i was a a kid i remember
him
i remember we had a little uh
datsun b210 i remember sitting in the
back of the car i remember him saying he
had to go to the statistician
to get the statistics done for his
dissertation i'm statistics like what's
that and that was sort of my first foray
into
there's a world out there i i you know i
liked cars a lot i was in the cars um
things are
i'm old enough to when i went to high
school there was no ap statistics right
you know if you liked math you did
calculus
um
and that's what you got
uh
and so i liked i liked physics i liked
cars i figured
i'd do something related to
making me a nice car
and
i ended up taking a stats course
along the way as a prerequisite and it
just
you know when you find what you want to
do and
you know god willing we all
have these experiences and get to see
enough to find the things that we really
like it just made sense to me like i was
like oh of course i remember the first
time i saw
a z-statistic and i was like oh yeah of
course you subtract off the mean yeah
and of course it has to be divided by
the standard deviation
and then and and and
you know that was you know 30 something
years ago that that happened
um
followed that you know finished went to
grad school finish that
uh did
academic think for a while environmental
statistics for a while
uh and this is just a fertile time to to
be in business and and try to make
things happen you know we're lucky and i
really that this this is something i
want to emphasize we are lucky to be in
this field at this time where people are
willing to pay money
for what we've dedicated our lives to
right like i always say had i stayed in
physics and then needed to find a job
after academia
you know i might have
it would have been just like how i
committed a crime right without a high
beta token and a particle accelerator
like what are you going to do with the
physics phd it's a crazy thing it's not
fair and so we're lucky that that that
you saw the lingua franca of the world
as the world has moved towards
digitalization as people are on their
phones is data science and i think we
owe
you know to the field to the craft
to be good at it
right and the champion and stuff a lot
of the questions that people have asked
have been about how do you mediate
basically a numeracy within
organizations and stuff like that and i
think whether we're going to be
successful with these organizations
whether these organizations are going to
be successful depends upon our ability
you know to sort of to to
to be clean and on top of our stuff in a
professional way
like to be actually good at it and and
and to
to to translate what we do into
meaningful impactful things
um
to answer more of this so when i hire i
i i i try to hire people i respect
i try to hire people who who who have
put the same love into their field
that i have
and and you know i was at when i worked
at my last job we had a conference there
was a
panel about the democratization of data
science and this may not be a popular
thing to say
but i said
on the panel
would you watch your surgeon democratize
right i just had eye surgery last week i
don't want my eye surgeon democratized i
want the eye surgeon who's
been studying since he was eight years
old
i want the eye surgeon who
you know who is a professional and good
at their craft
and and one of the things i think
statistics is beset with because it's
the lingua franca is that we get a lot
of
we get a lot of unprofessional activity
and behavior and participation
uh
in something which really really really
requires you know even a higher level i
i when i still teach statistics i still
teach a couple classes for seton hall
and and i say the kids and they have
difficulty with it
i'm quoting somebody else now i'm
quoting uh um
dick devoe a professor
at a williams college he says math is
like music statistics is like literature
you need to have a body of experience
and able to to be able to
uh uh apply statistics
uh in a mature professional way right
you can't just jump into it and
haha t-tests i'm good at that let me
throw that at everything right like and
and i think that
one of the things i hope that we get in
statistics in in data science
is is more of a sense of community and
guilt so that we can
and this may not you know enforce some
standards it's important for the
survival of the field
definitely thank thank you for that
perspective
and frank i just see you unmuted slowly
you jumped in there with what you were
gonna say
yeah i i don't i don't know if kobe saw
my question in the chat as he was
answering as he was speaking to that
idea of standards in the field and you
get a lot of noise and people just
jumping in and using their t-test but
um
i right there there's a little bit of uh
right personal
like looking at myself when i ask this
question um but i feel like i've put in
a lot of work in trying to understand
and make sure
when i find insights with data uh or or
put something out there in the world
that i really do my homework and i kind
of put my heart into it because
um i'm always afraid that someone's
gonna
say like
frank you're an idiot right like that
scares the heck out of me and i i would
imagine if i feel that way i have people
on my team and throughout my
organization who feel the same way so
right where's that balance between we
need professionals and we need people
who've thought a lot about this and like
how do you know when you're there
you know you i love that you said that i
love
your background i love the books behind
you
i'm gonna
you know one of the people who i really
really
like and look forward to and then and
look up to if you can put like that uh
donald knuth right the
um the guy who was the concrete method
professor at stanford and he's got a
bunch of uh lectures and conversations
on youtube and so they somebody asked
him a similar question to what you asked
and he just said like i i was always
afraid of not knowing enough i was
always worried that i hadn't i hadn't
done enough i hadn't learned enough i
hadn't respected what i was doing enough
to to get better at it and he says he
kept that sense throughout his life and
he feels like that's what allowed him to
be successful is
is having a higher sort of you know
thing to answer to right and and that
doesn't have to be like i think you know
using words like fear now that may not
be the right way to describe it it's
your craft
right and you're doing something with
your craft and and then i tell this to
my students
you may not remember me you may not
remember the text but you will remember
studying your brain will remember
the synapses changing this act of going
through learning something and being
good at it uh and that's a gift you're
giving yourself right and and if we
respect
that gift
then the organizations you know the
companies these business firms that we
that we're in
get the benefit of of of that self-love
if you want to put it that way and i'm
i'm i'm merely quoting battle news now
appreciate that
thank you kobe and alyssa i see you have
a follow-up question too if you want to
jump in
i think i think it's one of those things
where i mean you know the
the anecdote of like
i i would need to go see an eye surgeon
for my eye
that's sort of like yeah if my eye needs
eye surgery but what if i just need a
new pair of glasses then a technician is
what i need right so
i do think that there is
sort of space for everyone along there
that continuum to fit together but that
means we need to actually create
cohesive communities
rather than being kind of binary about
these definitions
in my humble personal opinion
oh sure you know i i you know it was it
was the optometrist who discovered that
i needed to go to the uh the eye surgeon
right and and and and for sure
you know you can't have in every um
america's best contacts and eyeglasses
the retinal specialist sitting there
waiting and flipping lenses back and
forth
um
there's definitely a
diversity
of
tasks if you want to put it like that
right yeah yeah i don't mean to say that
i know we have it's a few minutes until
the top of the hour here so i was just
scrolling through to make sure i didn't
miss any questions and i see there's one
more anonymous one
that was how seriously would you
consider a candidate
whose language of choice was not what
your team predominantly uses
but who was otherwise on point
you mean like like english french
spanish i think they mean probably are
python
oh oh yeah yeah i don't even ask you
know i that that's unimportant i mean we
do so we we do mainly in python just
because that's
what that's what's going down these days
but you know i'm old enough who even
knew what python was java right i'm old
enough to know c plus plus i'm old
enough to know pascal
i think if you know how to program you
know how to program and you can learn
new languages that so i will say that i
don't think that the way in which many
recruiters search for good people
is sufficient if you're looking for
keywords and i know sql and i know this
you're not getting a scientist you're
getting somebody who who learned a
package any of if you're good you're
dedicated your craft you're going to
learn whatever python will not be around
forever let's just say that yeah so i
don't we're not language agnostic
quick follow-up on that then what is the
best way to then
find find the right people or recruit
the right people if it's not necessarily
like those
words on the resume
you did like in all things it takes time
this is like everything you know back
when i did environmental statistics and
i spent a large part of my career
worrying about uh hydrology and
wastewater treatment
and if i had to summarize all of that
which is basically it takes time like
you can't rush cleaning water
um and the same thing you read
somebody's resume talk to people
have a network
of people you know i've been doing this
stuff 30 years so i know people who've
passed through different organizations
people different places people who have
students
uh and then the interviewing process i
think is
is super important and then and also and
i'll say this for people who are
interviewing which you know i'm a person
too who interviews
you want to be as selective at the job
that you choose to give your time to as
the places are being
you know selective with you and i know
in this country particularly
because we have no social safety net you
know there's always this power
differential but but it goes both ways
and i think that's again one of the
things that's nice about this field at
this moment
is is that if you've devoted a long time
to your craft
uh you know the need is so high that
you're able to sort of be particular
uh it's it's yo your job is a big part
of your life
um you're gonna spend a lot of time
doing it
you know marx believe that that craft
you know is the essential sort of
meaning of existence and stuff right so
so these things are super important and
being happy at what you do
and being an organization where you're
able to be happy at what you do it goes
both ways
awesome yes i um
i had one kind of final um
really enjoyed the the conversation um
my uh
my uncle is in the music industry and
like our family just loves it so it was
really fun for me just to kind of hear
um but i was kind of curious like uh
you mentioned
network and it kind of like spurred this
idea in my head of like this
giant network graph of
artists and you know
basically different
record companies and spotify and apple
and like do you guys ever look at that
network at like it or or at least like
try to visualize like
all of those different connection points
uh so there's this i i i'm forgetting
the name it's escaping my head right now
there's this interesting
graph that this fellow put together
art is that art of knowing but there's a
sound of noise many noises 100 noises uh
you know i'll send it i'll figure out
what it is now send it to rachel to pass
out to the group
but uh somebody has taken the data
you're describing and created this
beautiful illustration on the internet
which is all of these different artists
arranged in these sort of sub
groups and clicks that by you know type
in genre like and really specific stuff
like house deep house deep trance house
deep trance house in brooklyn and
on this this website you can sort of
pass through this illustration click on
something it'll play you representative
sounds on it it's the sort of thing
you're describing let me just figure out
what the website is i'll pass it to
rachel and maybe she can pass it to the
group after the call
yeah no that would be awesome
definitely thank you so much kobe and
one last final question i'd love to ask
you is and you could share this with
that other link as well
are there certain books or podcasts or
things that you generally listen to that
you'd recommend that we all check out
i'll send a list
okay
perfect well thank you so much for for
jumping on and and sharing all your
insights with us i really appreciate
your time thank you rachel thanks guys
thank you all for joining too
hopefully see you all next week
same place same time have a great rest
of the day
you